top of all the excitement at the red
carpet stage there is a massive football
festival going on at the nfl draft
experience it is interactive there's a
whole lot of fun activities people are
really considering it deep most popular
or one of the most popular aspects of
this whole draft experience and
therefore we're going to go live to
kirsten covering your nfl experience
hey bro hey brian and denise it's loud
here they got great music playing we got
families turning out in record amounts
day number one by far they expected the
most attendance but i gotta say the last
couple hours it's really picked up
people are liking the cooler
temperatures we're here inside the
gallery all the families are coming in
taking pictures throughout various
stages hi everybody
all right and they're checking out those
sparkly helmets
it's been a fun fun day this is just a
real fun family event and best of all
it's free
it's a family affair on day two of the
nfl draft experience in las vegas have
you been to an nfl experience before our
first time we live in southern
california
so close we had to come this family of
four big time seahawks fans because dad
grew up there but now that they're only
a short drive away they frequent vegas
as much as possible naturally they had
to come for this monumental draft
experience and they were here of course
when vegas opened back up before the
world got turned upside down this week
they are all about the interactive
exhibits the fun free family activities
and people watching energetic yeah what
do you love about it um i don't know i
like the energy of the people
i like all the people yelling